I've seen the animation for the Futurama
Simpsons crossover and it is awesome
really I love it there's going to be a
lot more Maggie this season lots of I'm
sorry I'm sorry Homer lots of over this
season there is gonna be a little Ralph
Wiggum this season so gentlemen would
you like to take some questions from the
audience we would there's a microphone I
believe set up it's being set up as we
speak so if you have a question please
line up in the mic make them to try to
make your questions so that we can hype
stuff yeah
with a little bit of paper on September
26 in London England at the Science
Museum our own Al Jean and Futurama is
David X Cohen are going to participate
in a symposium called
the mathematical secrets of Simpsons and
Futurama based on a book The Simpsons
and their mathematical secrets by Simon
Singh so there you go go to London in
September we will have Hank Azaria Nancy
Cartwright
yeardley Smith new music from The
Simpsons Weird Al Yankovic will be their
surprise and I'll be there in the
audience I might be there on stage too I
want to answer one question before its
ass The Simpsons will age finally but
only one day
thank you looks like we have a question
yes hi I'm honored to be the first
question the Halloween the treehouse of
horror I was wondering in the past why
you guys decided why you decided to show
it afterwards instead of before ordering
there's this horrible American tradition
called the world series for many years
is preempted us but after a long and
bitter fight wearing an axe over this
year
these are baseball has granted us
October 19 for once before Halloween the
treehouse of horror did did Aaron oh
he's come on up and claim your prize let
me just fill in a couple other
permittees to really quickly September
28 is the episode where Susan's meet
Family Guy on Family Guy the same guy is
where me and my character who
unfortunately passes away and November
day since around and then we will
crossover with the cast of scooby-doo to
find Casey Kasem's back
is that too slow one of those isn't real
go ahead with your question
a my name is William I love the Simpsons
forever it's been going on hopefully for
the rest of my life is there a way to
inject fresh blood kind of into this
series no we don't accept the
transfusion see nobody nobody quits
everybody everybody who's ever worked on
the show is still on the show I'd like
to give a shout out right now you know
people who are fairly rarely mentioned
but Bonnie Kayla the original casting
director has been with us since the very
beginning she's in the audience
someplace and 20th Kauffman who we've
been working together since 1987 on The
Tracey Ullman Show which is publicizing
the show and doing a fantastic job
the woman who has to listen to
everything we say and turn it into a
script Jack what happens every right
assistant is here today in fact that
most of this audience is made up of
people who work on the show
and that question we have a next
question please
my question is for Matt Groening I went
to the bongo cause booth he said you
sometimes go over there to sign but not
official it's not drawn stone so I just
want to know this year will you be going
to mondo Bongo comments tent and signing
autographs
I'm actually gonna be at the Casper the
Friendly Ghost
booth for some reason no discussion some
of us are going to be deader than Fox
booth signing for 45 minutes I will be
at the bottom of this sometime this
afternoon so yes I wanna say pick me
decide I can't draw he can do a great
mathematical equation
I caught up and grab one of these nifty
weird-looking Homer dolls
speaking of that here's our next
question
there's a huge chicken fight between the
two of them and I believe Parliament and
the family got a session later in the
day I've seen the whole upside I think
it's terrific it's a double episode
we're running you know the double
episode it's a Family Guy episode not a
citizen's episode we don't know really
what they're doing
no essentially you know it's good
but since 10:28 you know when there was
a Family Guy
panel and they're gonna I think they're
going to preview some episode I'm huge
values and that watching this is a
little kid and I want to know are we
ever gonna see Frank Zappa in a crowd
scene ever again Frank Zappa was
actually a friend of mine and he when he
was alive he died 1993 he said he he was
sick but he said he would like to come
down and mumble into the microphone for
the citizens and unfortunately he got
too sick we were not able to have him on
the show he also wanted we were putting
together since these albums at the time
and we were going to do a Simpson eyes
version of his song let me take you to
the beach sometime we'll see if an
animator sneaks them in yes he will
appear
maybe it'll be me speaking in episode 6
20 great question come on up and grab
your 14 season DVD set
holographic explosion news hi guys
huge fan real excited about The Simpsons
Futurama crossover episode I gotta ask
cuz everyone's wondering is there any
chance for the future on resurrection
there's two things that never die
science fiction and animation Futurama
has got it all say however some people
who worked on the show are actually
having waffles tomorrow morning so we're
going to talk about creatively we got to
do a lot of what we wanted to do it was
fun to be resurrected over and over
again we probably had more final
episodes than any other animated show
and we were really proud of the final
episode of the series which by the way
was nominated for an Emmy
you know even though we thought the
show's wrapped up really nicely
everybody who worked on the show luck
working on it and what would love to
work together again so who knows maybe
if there's a network out there that
wants us give me the ball
come meet your friends sheets around the
final episodes collection episodes 1
through 200 we just happen to have a
kdrama DVD set hi guys James from Brazil
and I guess you know my question what
he's referring to was the fact that the
Simpsons apparently predicted some of
the some of the results of the World Cup
well you know Bob immediate Germany
beating Brazil two to nothing and people
online are dying it was 7 to 1
I don't think it was pretty good if you
better way my crystal ball had a smudge
in it that day we could approaching the
school but it wasn't all of course it is
and we kind of predicted Niemeyer and
Brazil is a wonderful country and you
know season go ahead sir I just want to
ask this can go to anyone what was your
biggest failure that turned into the
biggest success
that's a jokey answer but there but the
fact is really the the very first
episode that we got back of animation it
was a disaster and we really thought if
the if the Fox Network saw that episode
they would cancel us immediately so we
actually hit that animation until we got
the results of our second episode back
and we realized that it was it was just
a it was a there was a fluke that we we
didn't know what we were doing and we
learned in one episode so and that a
little bits and pieces of that part of
the original original episode are on the
first DVD set with appropriately
horrified commentary no I just have a
quick answer for some one thing which is
the Susan's ride you know because the
first time you throw up I mean it really
and I think it's the best thing just
about that we ever did both universes
now it makes us throw up the other
citizens ride at Universal
I took my
my kids on the very first time and I say
that I promise you that your mind will
be loved being blown in three seconds
what's the ride begins and they said
quit Titanic dad and it will blow your
mind within the first 30 seconds of the
ride I guarantee it go go to Universal
it's really good
and speaking of Universal Studios we
have an official Universal Studios Bart
Simpson flushed out with you its
affiliate with Fox Universal let me see
it's all confusing that was a good
question though man yes
hi I'm a huge fan of your work at Lucky
trauma
I love the Simpsons and my question is
for Matt a trip to Washington and the
drove through Portland which is where
you grew up
it's Springfield based on Portland
Oregon well when I was a kid watching
television and much older than almost
everyone I eat here but there was a TV
show called father knows best and that
took place in Springfield and I as a kid
assumed that that meant it was the
Springfield near Portland and I was so
excited that a TV show actually took
place nearby then when I grew older I
found out that there Springfield is is
the second most common place name
in the united states the number one is
Lincoln I didn't think that Lincoln was
as funny as Springfield or had the
potential for being funny so that's
where it's greenfield latest wrinkle it
was supposed to be whatever state you're
from that's the idea
it's everywhere and what over the years
the way Springfield has sort of entered
the culture is really funny and one
thing we are doing is we have a
Springfield mural in Springfield Oregon
that's going to be unveiled in the end
of August that kind of time to be
determined exactly and we're hoping that
that would inspire other Springfield's
to do their own Springfield girl there
was a there was a elementary school that
opened in some place in Florida and they
allowed the kids to pick the name of the
school and the kids overwhelmingly voted
for Springfield Elementary you know the
parents in the prints floor area they're
all so delighted that kids picked such a
sweet name and then they found out that
it was the Simpsons and they wouldn't
let them do it
I hope even for you we have a I never
Futurama blu-ray so come on
next question please
hi first of all not to kiss up but Mack
rating you're one of my heroes
thank you for Simpsons if in Toronto
thank you very much how did you come up
with this thing that became so massive
how did you come up with The Simpsons I
invented this question many many many
times so I try to mix it up so this make
me alive I won't go to the n3 then how
do you come up with something it's the
result of watching television and
growing up and thinking this is you know
what part and should be better pretend
should be more exciting they should be
stranger they should be you know kids
should be bad at her concerns just like
cartoons were kind of sappy and it got
worse and worse though the older I got
when we were kids there was the
Flintstones and the Jetsons and top cap
and Jonny Quest then there was that that
was in the 60s and then cartoons kind of
died down
this is primetime and by the time
just before the Simpsons came around the
only thing you on TV in prime time
animated it was Garfield about that we
can do better than Harvey and so that's
sort of working from from watching TV
see that's what I'm saying
to watch more TV keep going for a couple
more you know we're gonna be around for
a while yeah you know we have two years
to run it into the ground and then
another ten years to go so it's off to
you guys though you got to keep you know
watching and tell all your pals Ewell's
used to keep watching and take you for
filling a ballroom at 10:00 in the
morning it's amazing
we usually have a blu-ray of the
complete 20th season of The Simpsons
come on yes sir any rock roots like kiss
gonna show up on future episodes
is weird on the end of it the rock group
he's gonna be at the Hollywood Bowl
number-one album and I did want to
mention one gets there that hasn't been
mentioned that erratic stare but a big
surprise mr. burns loses all his money
to Elon Musk
and Frank Zappa will be in the crowd is
anyone playing tapped out sir clearly a
wonderful tapped-out hoodie for you guys
my name is Robert my question is for a
man in the 90s the Simpsons were such a
groundbreaking show as far as family
dysfunction and everything I did as a
kid my dad blamed on bar influencing me
so my custody is decision when it comes
back from producers or executives about
a bar talking back to his father and
being disrespectful and did you
encourage her writers to do stuff like
that
whether was oh yes it was always
at the very beginning of the show
because the idea was up until the
Simpsons came on it's additional
generally cartoons Racine is for kids
and the theory was that you don't want
to do anything that would influence kids
badly or or confuse grandma you know so
so we went a different direction and I
would say it's it's due to these people
and all a lot of people that aren't here
today it's a huge collaborative effort
and what we try to do is reinvent the
animation as an adult art form and that
stuff that was our that was our excuse
for every bad joke that we ever did that
was that standards and practices didn't
like I said this is not a show for kids
it's a show for adults and then we knew
we had them the kids were tuned in
anyway I had to that the idea of
animation being for kids only was
something that really creeped out in
this country I would say in the early
sixties when basically the people who
are making animation for adults Warner
Brothers cartoons and even Disney
cartoons that were made for adults for
some reason there was sort of segregated
saying no now you're making kiddie
cartoons for Saturday morning and by the
way it doesn't happen anywhere else in
the planet and I mean every time we go
to an animation film festival it's like
oh wait a Domitian is for adults and
here in you know in
it's in England and in Japan it's only
the United States that this idea of
innovation being for kids so we are glad
to bring it back out of that position
just one we are bad for kids that's
their own kids here today kids gonna get
these jokes and it doesn't matter you
don't have to get a reach out that the
the the little clip reach out just down
a clockwork yellow obviously that is a
parody of Clockwork Orange by Stanley
Kubrick from 1971 and there were
references to what Eyes Wide Shut and
2001 and Barry Lyndon and the fake moon
landing and Stanley Kubrick there so
yeah so you know you don't have to get
everything it's still it's still good
grow up read a few books watch a few
movies and you'll you can come back and
watch them since morning not only can
you watch them since where you can watch
Simpsons marathon on August 21st when we
say 24/7 we mean 24/7 approach for your
product this is nifty it's a one of the
greatest guest stars collectible manager
figure who knows what's inside yes hi
Matt we're eternally grateful for this
show you gave us in the Simpsons it's a
very special show to me and my family my
question is in the 20 plus years you've
all been doing this
since what is one of the favorite
episodes to you that really stands out
in your mind you know you guys have your
favorite episodes
what's his name the guy who hated home
yeah I've seen most of the episodes
afraid of that that episode it just
seems like that was one of a few times
we acknowledge that it would be really
really unpleasant to work with somebody
like Homer Simpson my favorite episodes
that I've directed is I always go back
to home in the cloud I just had a lot of
fun with an episode and I thought that
came out terrific and what I thought was
a terrific script so that's one of my
favorites I really at least and the
story flowers around Elgin and we're
gonna I really got smart and he really
became friends with Lisa I directed
homers phobia and that is also one of my
favorite shows was one of my favorites
is tank squirt Nick Scorpio only moved
twice that one was Brad Bird said it
shouldn't work but it really does and we
we've got now we've done this show for
so long but it has been really fun to
actually get some of the non Simpsons
animators who we love so much to do
their own couch gags and we've had great
ones by Bill Plympton
John Chris for Lucy Sylvain so made the
director of Triplets of Belleville and
we've got some surprises coming up this
season that are going to really make you
wonder what the heck you're watching I
know what he's talking about it yes
the weirdest Kazekage we've ever done
we've got ones that are so night matched
its will change your DNA
excellent question come on down and get
this wonderful citizens tapped out
poster number 61 of 2500 my question is
will Bart man be showing up next season
he does show up in Bongo Comics quick
plug nicely done come on down and get a
Simpsons 16th season blu-ray adventure
time including singing the spider theme
song
duteous better poo come on down we have
a really wonderful nifty plastic cup
with a straw
I'm sorry yes sir hi Matt my name's
Randy first of all you undersold the
ride it's the most amazing ride ever
made anywhere I've got four kids they
all our witness in American history and
world history not for public education
they'll all tell you is from The
Simpsons it's unbelievable when you guys
go through your creative process do you
have world events that you want to work
in do you just I mean how does it how do
you fit in these great history lessons
they say first thank you for seeing me
undersold something you know we're
trying to do jokes about every single
thing that we can the writers are all
very well educated and the end the
animators are eager to strut their stuff
so yeah we like to you do like to make
references to all kinds of history and
you know it you know when you study
history sometimes they say no one's
going to use for you know there is you
can become and
right in your cartoon show there you go
Esther is useful it's damaged like a
Star Trek debated whether the other
thing too is I'm always impressed that
yeah we can put in something very
topical at the very last minute because
if something comes in we can write a
joke and do some animation like
sometimes a week before we air so that's
one of the ways we try to stay right on
top but your story I'm totally say they
had a joke of years ago about the Soviet
Union before the sugar and the Soviet
Union broke up so they could fix the
joke but now they're coming back
together so we can put the original joke
back yeah
come on down this is a tough tumbler no
matter what you're drinking it looks
like you're having a beer speaking of
tough use while driving
you